hello reject nation I'm Greg outlaw and
I'm John Humphrey well saying yours and
senoritas we're gonna talk about the
curse of La La Llorona I am super
excited to do this trailer man the first
one was appropriately creepy anywho
before we hop into that I want to say
muchos Gracias to all who have been
following us on our patreon page over
there we do weekly
croisé and we also do TV show reaction
stream alongs for several shows that
includes my hero academia Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood just started out
one punch man finish all of attack on
Titan you know it is supernatural season
2 right now yeah Gotham Riverdale but
transferring that a whole cuz now he
started the haunting of Hill House for
the fair use rules we do reaction
highlights with footage included for
Supernatural one punch man my hero
academia and Wayne which also is
assumable a home that's a mouthful for
me to say right there and he does music
video coverage let's get to this
I'm very sorry about my loss I can't
imagine how
she looks pretty mad yeah
I'll see that's what we're doing
so you don't get any rocking chairs just
like that now a whole bunch of people
know how to say no Road crews man zu the
hardest priest ever
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
pretty
[Laughter]
the other is the habit rate of the
voices to make sure we say man after
watching Romo I'm so excited for this
movie
oh yeah X equal the Mexican family is
having hard times this is exactly my cup
of tea
oh yeah and the naked stick fighting
guys going to save yeah she found a
newer better suitor to cure her
you know grief over the insanity of
murdering her children I feel like my
opinion on this trailer is uh pretty
solid guys I'm gonna give you all an
opinion on the yes I agree already must
be the most pretentious [ __ ] I've said
in a long time I am is all opinion about
the lawyer on you guys right now bits of
wisdom engine I I feel like this is
gonna be of like in terms of script wise
sure it's just a trailer but I've get
the strong impression that it's probably
gonna be a rather generic horror film
that's gonna be strongly elevated by a
unique sense of direction with its
visuals and its camerawork because that
was the most gripping part of all this
like a lot of this seem like this is
technically on paper seems pretty cliche
and pretty generic yeah but a lot of the
way the the symmetry of the angles and
the way it's really mixed up and the
performance is - I imagine will elevate
the movie as well but specifically the
direction of this movie you know just
seeing this trip this one specifically
not the last one but this one made me go
I can see why this guy is James Bond's
new buddy to take over the contrary 3
yeah probably my biggest takeaway from
this trailer is like I don't know
exactly how this particular film is
gonna go cuz I feel like the only issue
that the conjuring universe has is just
whether or not this particular script is
gonna flesh out its characters or not
because they always have like or and
your marks and stuff but yeah like just
the visual confidence at this trailer I
was like I get why they probably tapped
this guy to make the conjuring 3 because
it looks really chilling I love the vibe
like this is a folktale I've been aware
of for at least a decent amount of time
this ever became a movie not to take all
the credit cuz you know it's not even my
culture but but you know I'm excited to
see this story come to life and it looks
like those elements would be the most
unique I like Linda Cardellini a lot I'm
like I'm happy that she's getting to
lead this well it really does have that
feeling I don't like there was one shot
in here that I'm sure both of us much
evil good when it's going up to the
house like you know who's evil too but
in a sense of Evil Dead more than just a
couple of cool shots of POV through the
spirit it does kind of have that vibe of
there's a spirit hunting you down yeah
there's a nice spirit but a demon
hunting you down it has that dark
paranoid kind of oh yeah and I don't
know if that's just like oh it's
cleverly cut trailer but it's awesome
stream music we talked about that with
the Pet Sematary trailer now a lot of
times you know you you like compose a
Kudrow bits of awesome like creepy story
cuz that's the vibe that you're getting
here with that sort of paranoia I really
like it and there are some moments that
could have because in the first half I
felt okay this feels very cliche that's
specially the rocking horse chair or
whatever that's the only cliche example
I got guys I'm out of it it's not like a
lot of ghost stories share similar
earmarks overall well even with the
final moment with the girl bathing yeah
that we've seen moments like that before
you know you think of Nightmare on Elm
Street or even The Grudge when she's
showering in the air and the hand comes
out through her hair but this I found to
be the creepiest because she thinks it's
her mom and it's actually kind of in
lines we love her yeah
la Llorona character anyway you know
because she's drowning yeah cuz she
takes kids because she's so in such
grief over the loss of her own so that
moment of almost maternal yeah helping
you along with the bath is like I feel
like that's a movie you moment you see
in a lot of
horror movies like this but in this
context I feel like works better and
actually sold that moment because I
wasn't in love with the actual payoff of
that jump scares so much yeah but uh
yeah the jump scare was at that game she
gets pulled back in was whatever yeah
but but the idea that it that what
scared me was the sequence jump scare
exactly the context is better than you
know the actual execution is scare and
that's what's important
this feels more like less less like the
kids I know this isn't a conjuring movie
but it feels less like a conjuring
spin-off movie and a little bit more in
tune with something along the lines of
if Guillermo del Toro and James Wan
produce something that's kind of what
has this feels to me we're like the
orphanage mama Bell like the family vibe
Mexican vibe yeah in the direction to
and like the whole tone of it just feels
a little bit like a hybrid of both of
those filmmakers coming together yeah
like I feel like a lot of people might
mistake this for being part of the
conjuring bigger picture overall and I
could totally see why but at the same
time it does seem like it has some of
its own earmarks and I really like just
these kinds of horror stories that are
based on folklore I like the look of the
cast it's gonna be cold as the Raven
Cruz being a priest and also just as a
you know here the father the son of the
Holy but as an American who doesn't
fluently speak Spanish that's always
extra scary when ghosts and creatures
don't speak your language yeah you know
well guys this does look crypt CREP a
CREP a look crypts are gonna live listen
I want to wrap this up with a page of
the day shout out for a man named Diego
Shai des Eaux Diego's been in this
situation Diego being a man of Latin
roots has been in this situation one too
many times
every time he based he's the only man I
know that does not shower but
only has to use a full blown bathtub
with bubbles ship like do you graduate
high school get past it man he should
know got her it is a long time ago Diego
has been a part of our patron page for a
long time now and we used to talk with
him often but lately it seems like he
just doesn't care to talk with us
anymore and it's kind of upsetting me
it's kind of upsetting me
I'm literally mad at you and hoping that
Lila Verona goes after you and steals
your soul because the fact that you
still bathe makes you a little boy
worthy of being murdered what if he's
already been snatched up by lawyer what
if that's why we haven't heard from
Savannah has stayed pledged to our Beach
yeah she made sure he's like this young
boy will never unpleasing and it all
comes directly to us that's awesome that
may be the twist at the end is she's
really just a puppet for us to get play
that's beautiful Diego thanks for being
part of our patron page from the
afterlife buddy we miss you and I'll
visit your grave soon you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell check sound page
around we got [ __ ]